et en tout cas les gars vous êtes bien
mise en valeur par vos masques
vraiment alors vous avez vu alors il y a
André qui est là bonsoir André merci
d'être là
bonsoir Armand bonsoir ça va bien Armand
ça va j'ai un peu la voix enrouée désolé
je sais pas grave je t'emmerde pas
elle est pas venue pour ta voix
salut Tony salut ça va bien Tony ça va
donc vous êtes content
tous les trois je sais que vous êtes
vous savez que vous vouliez pour séduire
Daniel
merci d'être là en tout cas les trois
vous avez vu que ces trois styles
différents
[Rires]
mais ils sont quand même assez curieux
[Applaudissements]
en fait Armand tu as vu Armand eh
perspicace
on voit clairement il va vite tu vois
tout de suite alors
quelle soirée vous organiseriez pour
séduire Daniel on va démarrer par André
non mais excusez-moi normal
[Rires]
nous sommes des épicuriens
alors moi je suis un grand fan de cinéma
donc j'aimerais bien faire avec Daniel
une avant-première
d'un film important ou même je sais pas
première film de quel type
plutôt dramatique dramatique et ensuite
qu'elle me fasse découvrir un resto dans
la capitale que je connais pas trop
d'accord pas mal j'ai un petit accent
donc l'Hippopotamus
mais ça c'est pour le film
ah ça c'est pas mal Tony
et à l'hôtel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi je propose qu'on garde on garde les
trois pour l'instant hein
c'est 3 styles différents tu vois tu as
voilà un garçon
exactement
un peu plus Indochine un peu plus
Nicolas Sirkis pour la deuxième étape on
va y aller cash on va arrêter de tourner
autour du pot Daniel tu as suffisamment
attendu durant ces 45 dernières années
ils ont tous les trois une question à te
poser mais ce sont des questions cocu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est pas ça la question
André tu as une question
à poser à Daniel est-ce que vous aimez
les jeux coquins avec de la nourriture
genre chantilly fraise chouquettes de la
mer excuse
[Rires]
dans tous les sens du terme pourquoi pas
[Applaudissements]
vous avez déjà fait des jeux comme ça
Daniel est-ce que faire l'amour avec
quelqu'un d'autre en pensant à toi c'est
tromper
avec quelqu'un d'autre en pensant à toi
s'est trompé en fait il est en train de
tenir il va pécho une autre meuf mais il
va pour ça quoi
pour l'instant je pense qu'il va plus
trop de ça à moi faut s'occuper de moi
faut voilà c'est moi c'est la personne
qui a perdu les fleurs
pour toi c'est la taille
non non
c'est l'envie c'est la petite flamme
donc la taille n'a pas d'importance
[Applaudissements]
regardez ce qu'il a fait avec un micro
féministe c'est quand même pas mal
pénis
pas de côté je vais vous demander
maintenant non enlevez vos masques pour
la troisième étape
vous pouvez les enlever totalement ah
ils ont pas les choses
[Applaudissements]
tu peux me faire des sushis là tu peux
me
[Applaudissements]
oui excuse-moi ça va
sur la vie de ma mère
c'est
[Applaudissements]
parfait la bonne nouvelle c'est que tu
restes avec moi quand ah oui c'est vrai
merci c'est gentil
alors les chéris bien sûr on ne peut pas
prendre une telle décision et peut-être
partir pour la grande aventure de la vie
sans se rapprocher physiquement pour ça
que même toi tu vas le faire
[Rires]
là c'est fini c'est un animal mort
comme un cheval mort je t'aime d'accord
les chéris on va démarrer par André
d'ailleurs c'est quoi ton vrai prénom
[Applaudissements]
voilà Zaki tiens-toi un prénom
[Rires]
[Musique]
physique
je pense qu'il faut faire une petite
danse
tu vas démarrer
ensuite avant
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je te rappelle que tu en stage
[Applaudissements]
le gars
je me laisse aller à chaque fois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sérieuse parce que là les deux qui sont
là ce soir Armand ou Tony ont vraiment
un crush pour toi Armand c'est vrai oui
bien sûr
lundi on est à peu près on sait pas qui
va souffler la bougie
Armand attention
dis la vérité est-ce que tu kiffes
vraiment Daniel bien sûr tu l'as vu dans
l'émission je l'ai vu il y a même avant
l'émission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une tête de taliban alors pas du
tout pas du tout
[Musique]
juste un déguisement
pas avec toi c'est que des bonnes choses
c'est que du bonheur est-ce que tu
kiffes vraiment Daniel oui
sur l'émission sur l'émission
que je suivais son état d'esprit
voilà tu sens tu peux partager avec elle
les deux très bien pourquoi choisir on
va passer à l'épreuve de danse
Armand ou Tony tu veux démarrer par 15
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gars allez rechercher le
rapprochement
[Musique]
alors il y a de la passion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas mal Tony c'est plus tu vois c'est
plus subtile
[Musique]
c'était comédien normalement on te prend
pas je me suis dit je leur ai dit non
non je suis pas comédien
l'heure du choix
a sonné Daniel
[Musique]
voilà
tu vas réfléchir dans ta tête
ensuite tu réfléchiras tranquillement
dans ta culotte
pour l'instant
c'est pas encore là de manger
pour l'instant reste tout ça au frigo
les séries vous qui avez suivi cette
séquence vous vous dites
l'amour a peut-être frappé à la porte du
studio l'amour à deux visages ce soir
[Musique]
le visage
d'Armand
très cool Armand qu'elle a l'air
tranquille et qui continuent se
transforme en véritable bête sexuel
[Rires]
de l'autre côté
le Rambo de la Corrèze
Tony
[Rires]
arrête
comme ça
non mais c'est vrai Tony qui a l'air
il savait prendre du recul et qui savait
[Musique]
ambiancée gentiment c'est une boule de
neige c'est une boule de tendresse
et là tu as deux boules dedans
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
parce que on est là quand même pour
rigoler mais si l'amour en plus vraiment
faire son travail c'est quand même et
que ça serait quand même extraordinaire
je vous laisse Armand et Tony un dernier
mot à dire à Daniel puisque c'est vous
qui allez conclure et après Daniel
choisira en son âme et conscience celui
avec qui elle partira peut-être pour 10
15 20 25 ans
Tony Armand est-ce que vous êtes
toujours aussi motivé Armand très motivé
Tony Tony toujours vous êtes heureux de
l'avoir aller encore plus belle en vrai
elle est comme
en vrai exactement
en fait il faudrait le haut de Tony et
le bas d'Armand
c'est Michael Jackson
il est dans 7 jours
merci et Chérie dans un instant vous
allez dire un dernier mois Daniel
regardez là elle est magnifique ce soir
s'habiller comme un petit bonbon on me
demanderait qu'elle suce
si vous nous rejoignez seulement
maintenant sachez que vous n'allez pas
être des car aujourd'hui
à quelques encablures de la Saint
Valentin
[Rires]
a presque un homme qui pousse l'amour
qui sait
c'est l'amour
tu as l'air très ringard l'amour
et rentre quand même
l'amour a décidé de taper
à la porte
de notre petit papillon du Vaucluse
[Rires]
tu as du Vaucluse
on aura notre moment pour l'instant tu
vas faire une histoire de trois quatre
cinq ans
tu es trop tout feu tout flamme Daniel
Tony et Armand vont dire un dernier mot
car eux ils sont vraiment venus
parce qu'ils te kiffent un Tony alors
qui veut démarrer allez Tony tu veux
démarrer
je viens de Marseille je suis venu
assurer pour te voir ça fait des années
que je te vois à la télé je te regarde
tout le temps TPMP je suis sûr qu'on a
plein de points communs plein de
l'âge plein de trucs des passions on
doit avoir plein de passions communes et
je pense il faut encore se connaître et
je pense qu'on pourrait peut-être faire
un petit bout d'histoire tous les deux
c'est pas mal
ah j'aime bien
quand même
tout seul d'accord franchement c'est
beau ce qui vient de dire
de la sincérité à Marseille c'est une
belle ville
aller retour qu'est-ce qu'il y a
quelqu'un derrière toi
c'est une caméra j'ai pas l'habitude
elle est là
pour toi je suis venu ici j'habite pas
très très loin mais j'ai fait l'effort
de venir ici parce qu'à partir du moment
on m'a dit que justement venait pour te
séduire je me suis dit allons-y tontons
donc allons-y pour un weekend ou voir
plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu vas nous donner les qualités de
chacun et après tu feras ton choix tu
peux nous dire aussi j'ai choisi pour
l'instant de rester seul et comme disait
Garou celui qui n'a jamais été seul une
seule fois dans sa vie
[Rires]
[Musique]
Daniel quelles sont les qualités de
chacun alors sincère et quand même un
peu fonceur pour Armand tout en retenue
timide pour Tony mais la braise quand
même qui est pas loin
[Rires]
qualité de chacun mais alors moi je
cherche en fait principalement une
épaule et un sexe et je pense que Armand
a les deux bien bien présent il a les
pôles et il m'a montré qu'il avait
[Musique]
parce que là
on est face à ce qu'on appelle un cas
d'école
donc là tu es en train de nous dire
tu as envie de faire un petit bout de
chemin voilà un peu ma tête sur son
épaule est-ce que alors tu peux dire un
petit motoni quand même mais oui mais
j'ai il y a beaucoup de choses j'ai
sentiments
tu es un peu trop jeune encore pour
gagner
tu vas me donner
[Rires]
j'ai peur de le briser un petit peu
[Applaudissements]
dans ta chance avec quelqu'un d'autre
c'est sûr et certain ça je confirme le
même jeu la semaine prochaine avec
Delphine et avec Béatrice la semaine
d'après donc si tu es libre
parce que Béatrice actuellement
séparation
Daniel madame
Daniel tu as choisi Armand est-ce que tu
veux faire le bisou qui va sceller bien
sûr c'est peut-être cette future
relation ou est-ce que tu préfères
attendre non mais on peut s'embrasser
pudiquement
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que tu veux dire par embrasser
uniquement on n'est pas obligé de se
galocher comme des bêtes quoi
Daniel tu fais comme tu le sens
le petit bisou de du début d'une
peut-être d'une histoire d'accord
est-ce que tu es prêt tu as envie
d'embrasser je vais vous demander de
venir au centre de la scène
[Applaudissements]
c'est juste pour que les gens alors les
Chéries sachez-le c'est ce qu'on appelle
ici le salon privé
c'est un salon privé Jack sol tous les
deux en fait ce que vous voulez
aimez-vous
[Applaudissements]
c'est doux et piquant à la fois un petit
peu comme
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous allez vous voir ou pas
est-ce que vous avez tenter le coup ce
soir
ou pas là comme ça c'est sympathique
franchement c'est il y a quelque chose
sur la vie de ma mère
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mand